how did Michael Corleone go from an
honorable Marine who wanted nothing to
do with his family's business to a
ruthless Mafia Don who ordered a hit on
his own brother his dramatic
transformation is nothing short of
remarkable when The Godfather begins we
meet the corleones a highly respected
and feared mob family run by Don Vito
Corleone Vito deals with some mob
related business while a gigantic
wedding for his daughter is going on
outside we're also first introduced to
Michael Corleone just back from the
Marines as well as his girlfriend Kay
Adams in these early scenes you get a
clear sense of Michael has yet to be
corrupted by his family shady and often
violent dealings he makes this
especially clear to Kay who's troubled
when Michael pulls back the curtain ever
so slightly on his family's line of work
that's my family okay it's not me this
is Michael at his most innocent a far
cry from his State at not just the end
of the first film but the trilogy as a
whole after not playing ball with the
head of another Mafia Family veto is
shot in the middle of the street forcing
his hospitalization Michael discovers
his father States after seeing a
newspaper headline Michael quickly
dashes to the hospital where his father
has been looked after only to discover
that the entire place is being cleared
out with no guards or any kind of
protection Vito is helpless and
extremely vulnerable to any manner of
follow-up attacks from his enemies
Michael quickly realizes this and
springs into action convincing a lone
nurse to help him move veto into another
room he's then greeted by Enzo a friend
of the family whom his father helped in
the past Enzo is visiting to check in on
veto after sending Enzo outside to pose
as a guard Michael shares a tender
moment with veto telling his father that
he's here to protect him I'm with you
now
shortly thereafter Michael is confronted
outside by Mark McCluskey a corrupt
police captain as well as a few of his
own men after some heated words Michael
is severely beaten by the police until
Tom Hagan and some of veto's Associates
arrive and de-escalate the situation
it's not only masterfully suspenseful
but gives us just a small taste of how
Michael can quickly take control of the
situation in his own way
after the hospital incident Michael
finds himself dragged into his family's
Mafia activity Michael's heated
interaction with McCluskey has led to
some tension between the corleones and
drug kingpin Virgil salazzo this is
because salazzo ordered the hits on Don
Corleone and McCluskey is on his payroll
salots so seemingly wants to smoother
situation over but Michael's older
brother Sunny the acting done suspects
something sinister looking to take
matters into his own hands Michael
pitches the idea of meeting with salotso
and McCluskey for a sit down where he
would kill them some Hagin the family's
lawyer advises against this as a Fallout
could reignite a war between the various
mob families despite Hagen's
recommendations Sunny opts to approve
Michael's idea and begins helping him in
planning out the head it's not personal
sunny
is strictly business
the night eventually arrives and Michael
after fishing a hidden gun out of the
bathroom kills both men in the middle of
a restaurant not only is it one of the
film's most brutally violent scenes it
also shows that Michael's descent into
darkness has officially begun the
innocent marimi met in the film's
opening scenes is slowly but surely
accepting his role within his family's
dark destructive dealings
following the murders of salazzo
McCluskey Michael's family wisely gets
him out of the country for a while to
avoid the Fallout to ensure his
protection Michael is sent to live in
Sicily under the watch and protection of
Don tomasino an ally of the Corleone
family it's here Michael gets a little
reprieve to enjoy life which isn't
difficult among the Landscapes of Sicily
he also falls in love with a local woman
named Apollonia vitelli Michael
eventually marries Apollonia with the
intention of spending the rest of his
life with her meanwhile back in America
Sunny is violently gunned down by a
Siege of gangsters at a toll booth
Michael is informed of his brother's
death and ends his time abroad seeking
to return to America with his new wife
however just before they depart Sicily A
Car Bomb intended for Michael goes off
with Apollonia still inside the vehicle
killing her for the first of what will
be many times Michael's dealings with
the family business have cost him
something he loves this is a key moment
for Michael's still ongoing
transformation as the death of his wife
ignites his role as ahead of the
Corleone family Michael
those Jesus
after his return to America Michael
reunites with Kay and Marisa they have
two children named Anthony and Mary it's
also during this time that Michael steps
in as a new dawn Michael's
transformation really reaches its apex
as he's now more than willing to crank
up his ruthlessness when needed this
final transformation is cemented during
the baptism scene it's here that Michael
takes control of the Corleone mob prior
to his death The veto tells Michael that
Don Emilio barzini the man responsible
for Sonny's death will be coming for
Michael next the prophecy is soon
revealed to be accurate Michael takes
action in the most brutal way possible
he wipes out the heads of all five mafia
families as Michael attends to baptism
of his sister Connie's child we're
treated to a brutal sequence of the five
heads being taken out in gruesome
fashion not only is the sequence a
testament to Francis Ford Coppola's
Cellar Direction but it effectively
cements Michael's Dark Descent into a
life of crime Michael's Life as a dumb
becomes increasingly difficult in the
events of The Godfather Part 2. set
three years after the first film when
we're reintroduced to the Corleone
family a Miss yet another large
Gathering Michael is firmly set as done
my offer is this
nothing the kind and bright-eyed young
man from the first film has already
become a distant memory replaced by an
eerily broken person however there's a
sensor Michael is becoming increasingly
more disillusioned with his role even
though he's forced to keep up a dominant
facade things get knocked for a serious
Loop when much like his father before
him Michael's life is nearly lost in a
mop head late one night a variety of
gunshots tear apart Michael's home
almost immediately Tom Hagan concludes
that the only way this could have
happened is if someone within the family
was secretly in on it as a result
Michael is a bit more paranoid and on
edge another Factor affecting his
crumbling mental state
in The Godfather Part 2 Michael tells
his older brother Fredo
[Applause]
I know it was you Freda you broke my
heart he says this after uncovering
Fredo's true level of allegiance to the
family it isn't until New Year's Eve
while he's doing business in Cuba that
Michael finally figures out that it was
Freda who sold him out it becomes clear
that Fredo knows Johnny Ola the right
hand man of mob boss hymen wrath Roth is
a likely suspect for who organized the
hits on Michael after this discovery
things are irreparably damaged between
Michael and Fredo with Fredo believing
he should have been the one to take over
when Vito died I'm your older brother
Mike and I was stepped over Michael
vanishes Fredo from the family but says
that he won't be harmed as long as their
mother Carmella is alive Carmella
eventually passes on which serves as a
cue for Michael to begin tying off Loose
Ends including Fredo
despite Connie doing her best to
convince him to forgive Fredo his time
is officially up one day while out
fishing frayder is shot in the head and
dumped into the water all while Michael
looked some with a somber glare most
important to note about the Godfather
Part 2 is that it's telling two stories
intertwined vetoes rise to power and
Michael's Fall From Grace the former is
set in the early 1900s and tells a story
of a young veto Corleone working his way
up the mafia ladder as we see vetoes
steadily and violently build what will
one day be the Corleone crime family we
have a front row seat to see it all
burned down by the time the credits roll
Michael has lost his wife and set up the
murder of Fredo so not only is Michael's
marriage finish but his entire immediate
family are all dead and last we see of
Michael in the film he sits alone on a
bench staring out into space though
judging by the music of Michael's
thousand yard stare we can safely assume
he's wondering just how everything could
go so wrong this somber conclusion is
the first taste of the more mentally
weathered Michael we end up seeing in
The Godfather part three when we catch
up with Michael at the beginning of the
Godfather Part 3 again at another family
gathering he's approaching his 60s long
gone into hopeful young guy we met back
in the first film replaced by a worn out
man with ample regrets one of the many
subplots active in the film involves
Sonny's son Vincent becoming
romantically involved with Michael's
daughter Mary creepy romance aside
Michael names Vincent as the new Don
after he chooses to step down
you won't be able to go back
you don't feel like me
good you can't talk about the Godfather
Part 3 without talking about Michael's
daughter Mary Corleone it's very clear
that Michael is still very protective of
Mary this is why he tries keeping her in
Vincent apart due to Vincent's organized
crime affiliations little did Michael
know just how well founded his fears
were especially when the film's shocking
climax rolls around after a night at the
Opera yet another attempt on Michael's
life is made on the stairs of the
building following some gunshots Michael
is wounded he then looks over to see
Mary who's been hit point blank in the
chest were then treated to a tragic
image of Mary's parents cradling her as
she dies with Michael letting out a
blood-curdling scream despite his best
attempts to walk away it seems the
powers that be needed to take one last
thing from Michael his daughter that's
when I thought I was out
they pulled me back in with one of his
own children now dead because of his own
past sins and decisions Michael has
truly become a Broken Man however when
it comes to the film's final image of
Michael this is where things get a bit
interesting in 2020 The Godfather Part 3
was recurred to better fit the vision
that Coppola originally envisioned were
three sequence scenes and altered
musical cues one such change appears
during the ending which originally sees
a frail and Gauntlet looking Michael
clearly at the end of his life in that
original see me see Michael all alone
succumbing to his old age and falling
out of his chair similar to how Vito
died in the first film in the recut
version however the film instead Fades
from old Michael to a quote that reads
when the Sicilians wish you chentani it
means for long life and the Sicilian
never forgets Michael has indeed been
blessed with a long life but when you
consider how much he's lost it might
just have been a curse
[Music]